this won't be a spoiler review since I
feel like there isn't a major rush for
people to see this show and the good
word of mouth surrounding Andor is
slowly bringing more attention to it
within andor's praise you have probably
heard that this is the best Star Wars
content in a long time and technically
that is true but to be fair there isn't
a lot of competition the book of Boba
Fett was pretty bad Obi-Wan was a
nightmare behind the scenes and on
screen and the Mandalorian is good at
times but it has its own issues Andor is
a clear standout in quality however
don't go in expecting a magnum opus that
is going to blow your socks off this is
a slow paced show that takes its time
with characters and plot progression and
everything it sets out to achieve is
done superbly and pretty much flawlessly
this shows a spy Thriller with a big
emphasis on drama and with that kind of
emphasis you need to create a colorful
cast of characters ironically out of all
the Star Wars content Andor has the most
interesting Ensemble which is really sad
consider during Obi-Wan just came out
and that show was so dull in terms of
character work for Andor we have Cassian
who is a good POV character for the
audience since he's getting ushered into
this new Rebel world he feels very
compelling because he's so reluctant to
join the cause and is instead swayed by
his own motivations he's not blindly
joining the Rebels for unknown reasons
that the writers don't elaborate on but
he acts realistically to serve himself
this in turn makes the plot a bit
unpredictable because it doesn't go down
that stereotypical path of the
protagonist turning into an immediate
good guy then The Supporting Cast I
think is Rock Solid and there are even
some Game of Thrones alumni who show up
like Lord Royce the wave and qyburn who
all do an excellent job as well as some
other notable supporting characters like
ibon moss and I'm not trying to say his
last name who was amazing in the bear
and Annie circus I adore Andy Circus and
I really hope he gets more live action
work because this man can act and he had
an engrossing mod monologue that's
filled with so much emotion then this
isn't even getting into the best part of
the cast which is Stellan Skarsgard if
this guy chooses a project then I'm
immediately interested in it given that
he's been on a hot streak and if he's
using Andor of all shows that bien then
there has to be a reason he is a
world-class actor and any line of
dialogue he delivers is done with so
much weight and gravitas his character
in the show is by far the most engaging
because he's at the center of the
Rebellion so any plot development around
him is always riveting this also ties
into Mon mothma because she's also at
the center of the Rebellion Big Bang
every scene she is in has so much
tension because she has to act very
carefully so she doesn't set off any red
flags this ties in a more political and
scheming aspect to the show that it kind
of shares with Game of Thrones it
actually makes the conflict of starting
the rebel Network as surprising Delight
because of how difficult it is here
characters don't just snap their fingers
and spawn in allies like in the movies
because that actually takes time and
lots of hard work this is where the meat
of Andor is and since the writing is
really well done it excels in these
dramatic aspects probably because the
show is being passionately made by Tony
Gilroy who also wrote Rogue one in the
Bourne trilogy so the man is goaded this
is not a kiss of Obi-Wan where Disney
forces it into existence it butchers the
original direction of the story to fill
the mini-series formats so the fact that
this show both has a great and solid
direction from a creative leader who is
dedicated to the project and great
actors who want to be in the show speaks
volumes for the quality of Andor along
with the fact that this actually feels
like a feature-length show because
Disney Plus shows have been gaining the
reputation of being like 30 minutes long
once you disregard the intro and outro
Andor has a few episodes of that
duration but most of them are about 40
to 50 minutes long so that's another
sign that the creators are putting care
into the story instead of rushing to a
conclusion there is no filler like the n
endless amount of side quests in the
Mandalorian and half of the book of Boba
Fett being flashbacks anzor follows
different perspectives in this expansive
universe and it all intertwines in a
glorious fashion now going into this
show it starts out pretty slow and I
honestly had a hard time getting through
the first two episodes given that they
had to set up a lot of material like
dozens of characters background and
motivations in cassian's backstory the
plot wasn't that engaging at that point
but it evolves and becomes more
interesting once cassim becomes
entangled with the Rebels the second he
gets into a room with selling
skarsgard's character it becomes really
fun so if you do decide to try the show
at least get to episode 3 because the
first three episodes have one Big Arc
and the other mini plot arcs that
casting goes down get even better also
Ander doesn't appeal to people who want
constant action in lightsaber battles it
has action in small quantity and the
show earns it by properly building it up
and having extremely satisfying payoff
as an example Cassian means a crew of
people and they decided to do a heist
and instead of having a fast pace where
right after meeting them they cut to the
mission casting instead has to learn the
operation and in turn meets the
characters everyone is very fleshed out
because of this and they all have
compelling backstories so when we
inevitably get to the action which is
also really well done from a writing
standpoint and visual standpoint we
actually care about these people another
big aspect of the show in terms of plot
and writing is that there isn't a
constant barrage of terrible mistakes
there's no Leia getting chased Through
the Woods by bounty hunters who can't
catch her or characters surviving
getting skewered by a lightsaber Andor
feels realistic and grounded and there's
nothing in the writing Department that
compromises that feeling because of this
in a more slow pace the show feels
significantly more gritty and foreboding
and since we are slowing down the
writers also give the villains over in
the Empire a lot of screen time at first
I was kind of scared these scenes would
be dull since it's a bunch of old people
talking about Security in politics but
that isn't the case the rendition of the
Empire here is very competent and makes
them seem much more menacing because
they are constantly on the heels of our
heroes and tracking them that's why
these scenes are so engaging because
they are directly tied to the plots
they're setting up new and interesting
characters there's even conflict amongst
the ranks to add even more spice and
it's actively intriguing because we
never seen this kind of meticulous
detail before in Star Wars that's one
major aspect about the show that I love
so much because Star Wars has such a
rich and immersive universe but because
of bad past writers on different
projects they essentially squander the
potential of the IP and it becomes very
Bland as a result Tony Gilroy brings in
that much needed feeling of depth and
fully explores everything tied to the
Rebels the Empire and how each planet is
being impacted thankfully this detail
within the world builds the Empire's
stronger antagonists and doesn't portray
them as buffoons it makes them feel like
a real intangible threat that is
pursuing Our Heroes which thankfully
there isn't annoying amount of
Stormtroopers constantly missing to make
the villain unantagonizing like an
Obi-Wan because when [ __ ] goes down some
characters who come to like will die the
show in that regard isn't afraid of
killing characters and that's refreshing
because it doesn't give off the notion
of plot armor that destroys any
semblance of tension it makes the action
significantly more intense despite us
knowing that Cassian will survive until
the events of Rogue one we don't know
the outcome of different Side characters
and how certain story elements will play
out that's why the show has to establish
likable characters and they do that
expertly going into a more Technical and
production point of view for Andor the
show still doesn't show any flaws for
starters every set piece is really
refreshing and is much needed since
almost every show so far has been said
in the dullness of Tatooine like we have
a mining planet that is being
destabilized by the Empire a more
mountainous planet that looks like the
best parts of Scotland Coruscant is back
and all the Interiors for the Empire are
so eerie and corporate and is so devoid
of Life given that everything is washed
out in white essentially contrasting the
rest of the production design in the
show this was really the first time that
I've been impressed by the sets for
Disney plus Star Wars content and I'm
happy that they are giving the show a
bigger sense of scale than the
Mandalorian as an example if they were
using the volume regularly then they
easily fold me because it looks like
they're using practical locations and
using VFX is a form of set extension I
tend to prefer this more because it
makes the world feel tangible when you
really build it it's infinitely more
impressive to me and is aw inspiring the
volume used well can blend into an
already existing collection of good sets
but when you primarily use a volume it
can become a little noticeable for the
VFX this isn't a show that requires a
lot of it since there isn't a big action
set piece in every episode so it's
primarily used to ground Us in the world
through environments Disney is not
sparing any expense and the VFX is very
immersive because it brings a staggering
amount of quality to the details of each
world and even when there is an emphasis
on V effects like this TIE fighter
flying over ahead it's very realistic
like watch this brief clip
through the interaction with the
environment and the characters being
scared to death and being deafened by
the loud noises establishes this as
being real then when the show decides to
go big with VFX it really blows you away
with the Striking visual design Andor is
just a beautiful show and even the
cinematography doesn't miss a single
beats the show hooks me really early on
with this long take focused on a
close-up of cassian's face as he's being
pestered by two officers it immediately
allowed Diego Luna to impress us with
his great acting and it was a very bold
shot so right away the show establishes
a high bar for cinematography the music
is also a major standout as well this
isn't like Obi-Wan where you probably
have no memory of what the main theme
was because here is very memorable the
composer for Andor is also the same
composer for succession and the main
theme for that show is Iconic so to say
the least he brings just as much talent
to Andor I particularly love the
emphasis being put on violins and it
gives a lot of the music within the
soundtrack such a beautiful and
uplifting endearing feeling it betrays
the notion of Breaking Free of tyranny
and gaining Freedom each episode opens
with a long logo of Andor and honestly I
haven't skipped one because I
immediately am put into a Wonder like
trance by the music that and the
soundtrack goes down some interesting
routes and the composer Nicholas brittle
even tries out a more synth style at
times it's a very refreshing soundtrack
and is pretty close to the Mandalorian
in terms of quality the Mandalorian to
me in terms of music is still my
favorite but that's because Ludwig
Goranson is one of my favorite composers
so yeah everything within the show from
the acting character work writing
different and fun story arcs tone tense
atmosphere and everything on the
production side of the coin is done with
so much expertise to the point that it
deserves to be watched this is a show
made with so much passion and Care put
into the story it may not have
characters people love going in to
immediately sell it but it does a
magnificent job of creating a rich to
roster of characters that you will
easily come to love I was very hesitant
going into the show but I ended up binge
watching it in almost one sitting thank
you for watching and let me know if you
guys have been enjoying Andor